what's up reject nations John Humphrey
comin atcha on a Saturday afternoon hope
you're doing well we don't cover a whole
ton of TV on this channel however I am a
big Rick and Morty fan the new season is
out I'm not a hundred percent caught up
yet I've seen the first episode but a
lot of life's been going on and I
haven't had a chance to really sit down
but this video popped up in my YouTube
recommended feed from the New York
Magazine and I grew up watching
Spongebob and has since graduated to
stuff like Rick and Morty and just just
the prospect alone of these two shows
even in a small silly way coming
together is very amusing to me I like
these weird little improv things that
Justin roiland and the Rick and Morty
team do so let's take a look at this
[Music]
Morty where are we right now oh gee
we're in the Spongebob universe show and
why because vulture the vulture website
how many wanted it to be here alright
okay okay so what do we do hold on let
me go talk to spongebob all right look
go to a part of Spongebob world where no
one's ever gone okay cut to a exterior
clench world types webbed oh yeah a
little clutch creatures are you're
piling into a diet don't and I'll take
you on as my downline and do it
and one couple in lines exhibits mundo a
female sponge sponge in and a male
sponge in thing I mean I have like only
moving on here it's just me and you so
why you keeping you guys I don't know I
guess I could have it'll be kind of a
lap time morning what do you think of
these tailing she's got a little bit
there out with the peel of Brooke go at
it Richie for here I'll bring over them
in a Rik designed some submarines when
you say we put on our sponge helmet get
out and have a little fun morning I
don't know come on show me what are we
going to do don't ask any questions
please follow me
ah camera pans over to the summer oh
[ __ ] your sisters in the back of my
vehicle
I'm sorry guys tied me up but I'm like
really hoping that actually I tell you
about swimming from you're talking about
poison
hi guys hydro prick why would you tell
your sister up morning flashback to the
reason where you type summer up 1976
cocaine do rigorous Richard King
Richard's White House is making the
hottest summer in of all the salads and
is on the radio as we pan to a
neighborhood in the book club summer cut
back to they can carry things I want to
let go only keep spinning I wanted to do
that I want I don't move at all
if you move even a little bit this
untying Ray could have irreparable
damage Rick but unbuttoned the stance it
produces the untying right which is pink
the length of a flashlight it has
buttons on it and totally g-rated to
straight hopes co-presenting looks
dangerous Morty relax summer
quit wiggling quit moving summer it's
3:00 - I can't I already set the
temperature you're moving around and
yeah the ship is budget Ryan comes
unseen event Prince Namor from the
Marvel Universe okay the front of creme
and hey Great Prince Namor here
wonderful hey I'm like the cool Aquaman
Hyrule regular Aquaman from the DC
Universe swims by crossover oh hello
thanks Oh Morty this thing's real
turning into a real who's who of
underwater characters yeah you're
telling me I just wanted to break up
arguing couple that was in lobby by the
snail Morty let's just collect a bunch
of these sponges and some sponges that
people can use the cleaner disgusting
filthy human body this voltar logo
dissolves up over this whole sketch the
the subtitle is vulture there's a reason
we react to content haha oh boy that was
interesting it's funny to watch people
improv especially people in this
position where it's like you know they
know this thing inside and out and they
spend so much of their time with these
characters writing these characters
being these chickens s and being these
characters elevator going up yeah I mean
now that was out that was clearly very
off-the-cuff not the most of Rory's Rick
and Morty bit I've ever seen I wish I
kind of dug deeper into the spongebob
world is because I think animation
crossovers are usually very fun even if
there are official and especially like
characters like Rick and Morty can go
anyway
and that's part of the charm but you
know there were some things about the
really cracked me up and that 1976 bit
was pretty golden just just as a piece
tying you up and that's it I mean this
wasn't quite as hype as I hoped it would
be but it was still pretty amusing I
would love to see some kind of spongebob
something or other happen in a future
episode of Rick and Morty or something
like that but yeah what do you guys
think have you seen this comment below
let me know your thoughts how you like
in season 3 of Rick and Morty and I know
we don't cover TV a lot on this channel
but if you want to know what we're
thinking about you know the shows that
we're watching and which shows we're
watching and stuff like that you can
follow us on the TV time app this video
isn't sponsored or anything but very way
to keep track of all your favorite shows
it'll let you know when new episodes are
about to air you can rank your favorite
characters you can get on and write
reviews you can make your own memes and
gifts a whole bunch of awesome features
inside that so give TV time a shot
follow us at the real rejects it's a
really terrific apt and yeah you
subscribe to the real rejects hit that
notification bell to get updated every
time a review or a video is up you can
check us out on patreon we've got a
whole bunch of exclusive content and fun
stuff over there come join our little
community if you so desire we got shirts
in our spread shirt shop thanks for
watching I am Det John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram and until next
time wobble of a dub dub